[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans votre 7,8 week-end nous allons
parler actualités mais aussi loisirs
voici les titres de ce vendredi 5 mars
pas de confinement le week-end en
ile-de-france et une accélération de la
vaccination
ce sont les deux annonces à retenir pour
les yvelines de l'intervention jeudi
soir du premier ministre jean castex
nous ferons le point et nous irons à
cette occasion hameau le département
commence le déploiement de son maxi bus
pour les zones rurales
nous parlerons également de la grande
collecte annuelle des restos du coeur
qui a lieu ce week-end
5 6 et 7 mars rencontre avec l'une des
bénévoles du comité des yvelines et en
plateau avec nous et manuel nodé
langlois président des restos du coeur
78 et puis une sortie pour ce week end
puisque c'est encore possible
l'arboretum de versailles chèvreloup
rouvre ses portes et ce sera gratuit
tous les premiers dimanches du mois
juste avant cela le premier ministre
jean castex est une nouvelle fois
exprimé sur la crise sanitaire jeudi 4
mars deux choses ont notamment été
annoncée la première les centres
commerciaux de plus de 10 mille mètres
carrés doivent fermer leurs portes à
partir de ce vendredi 5 mars minuit dans
les 23 départements sous surveillance
renforcée
les yvelines sont évidemment concernées
l'autre annoncé l'accélération de la
campagne de vaccination dans ces mêmes
23 départements 135 mille doses doivent
être alloués dès ce week-end dans les
territoires concernés dont 51 mille en
ile de france le gouvernement a pour
objectif 30 millions de personnes
vaccinées d'ici l'été
enfin les habitants des départements
sous surveillance renforcée sont aussi
priés par le gouvernement de ne pas
quitter leur région ou leur territoire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
et ce vendredi 5 mars à doha a aussi été
choisi par le département des yvelines
pour présenter son maxi bus à maule
destiné à la vaccination contre le coc
vide 19 des plus de 75 ans il va
sillonner les zones rurales dans les
yvelines
les précisions de grégory canal et il
sera stationné à chaque fois à proximité
directe des salles des fêtes levac cybus
fait étape ce jour-là à maule mise en
place par le département des yvelines
est l' agence régionale de santé il
servira à acheminer des doses files
heures elles sont à destination des
personnes de plus de 75 ans vivant dans
les communes rurales
les vaccins sont stockés dans le
véhicule préparé avant d'être administré
à l'intérieur des salles des fêtes par
une équipe médicale
un dispositif complémentaire au centre
de vaccination déjà en place
levac six bus permet d'aller sur des
communes qui sont pas forcément
aujourd'hui couverte par l'ensemble de
vaccination est d'aller au devant de la
population qui a des difficultés pour
accéder à une vaccination dans ces
centres de vaccination pour aller au
contact de nos concitoyens qui ne
peuvent pas forcément se dépasser
facilement en particulier donc les
personnes âgées parce que ça n'est pas
très simple pour elle de se rendre dans
des lieux de vaccination éloignés
levac 6 buts se rendra dans les
intercommunalités de gally mauldre de
coeur divine et des portes
d'ile-de-france 120 doses seront
administrés à chaque journée de
vaccination elles profiteront villages
des alentours l'opération à maule ce
vendredi 5 mars était adressée également
aux habitants de cinq autres communes
ces personnes ont été identifiées
directement par les municipalités
quand on en arrive en âge surtout comme
moi qui n'est absolument plus aucun
parent aucun ami aucun enfant
je suis contente d'avoir de pouvoir être
soigné un symbole je pense que ce
démarrage a plus le centre de crespières
qui se met en place la semaine prochaine
je crois que ça va ça va rassurer
beaucoup de monde au delà du taxibus
neuf centres de vaccination sont en
place dans le département quatre sites
supplémentaires doivent ouvrir dans la
semaine du 8 mars et on va maintenant
parler sport et plus précisément de
cyclisme dimanche 7 et lundi 8 mars le
département va accueillir les coureurs
du paris nice pour nous parler de cette
édition 2021 michael l'umih d'euros
journalistes de la rédaction
bonsoir bonsoir alors ce paris nice sera
forcément un peu particulier avec la
crise sanitaire
oui tout à fait on a eu peur on a
tremblé jusqu'au dernier moment on
pensait en parler notamment d'un
possible confinement le week-end en ile
de france et d'une possible annulation
de la course au soleil
mais cette 79e édition aura bien lieu ce
dimanche les coureurs partiront de saint
cyr l'école pour deux boucles dans les
yvelines
le lendemain ce sera la petite commune
de waimes ville sur mon siège je ne sais
pas si vous connaissez eléonore mille
habitants seulement qui accueillera le
départ direction le loiret un vrai
soulagement pour le département qui
accueille le paris nice depuis à 12 ans
qu'est ce qui va changer cette année au
niveau de l'organisation qu'elle alors
pour comprendre ce qui va se passer ce
dimanche à saint cyr l'école
il faut se souvenir du dernier à tour de
france et notamment de la dernière étape
à mantes-la-jolie les organisateurs
avaient créé une véritable bulle à huit
clos sanitaire autour de l'événement
pour résumer il y aura des systèmes de
filtrage pour limiter le nombre de
spectateurs autour du site au départ sur
le principe de une personne tous les
quatre mètres carrés seuls les rivera
une personne accréditée pourront se
rendre sur le site les cours ne pourront
pas approcher le public les sportifs
parce qu'on brièvement sur le podium
pour les présentations ils pourront
répondre aux questions des journalistes
mais de loin et sans contact les
coureurs sont tous soumis au départ de
l'épreuve à des tests pcr comme
l'ensemble des personnes qui sont autour
de l'événement j'ai dû par exemple faire
un test pcr moi-même pour avoir mon
implication et ce dimanche et je suis
négatif donc vous pourrez le lire sur
place les spectateurs sur la route
eux ne seront pas soumis à ces contrôles
et ils pourront regarder tranquillement
passer le peloton
par la fenêtre ou sur le bord du chemin
mais attention pas d'attroupement de
plus de 6 personnes et bien sûr la vente
d'alcool est interdite et la
consommation d'alcool est interdite pour
le public
est ce qu'il y aura des têtes d'affiché
du coup malgré ce contexte à une terre
dimanche alors pas énormément à eléonore
la crise sanitaire ne permet pas d'avoir
un plateau très fourni en star cette
année certains ne viendront pas à cause
des quarantaines mise en place dans à
certains pays les deux précédents
vainqueurs du tour de france le coût en
longs bien égal à bernal et le slovène
tadej aux catcheurs ne seront pas
présents tout comme le chouchou du
public français julian alaphilippe mais
plusieurs têtes d'affiché seront quand
même présente sur ce paris-nice prix
mostro glitch deuxième du dernier tour
de france saura là il y aura également
le tenant du titre l'allemand maximilian
cherche man est un solide duo pour la
groupama fdj avec david de gaudu pour le
général et arnaud démare pour les
sprints les passionnés de cyclisme vont
donc pouvoir quand même voir du
spectacle dans les yvelines malgré ce
contexte particulier merci michael et
demi d'euros pour toutes ces précisions
et je rappelle que le départ de cette
79e édition du paris-nice sera donné ce
dimanche 7 mars depuis saint cyr l'école
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
juste avant d'accueillir notre invité du
jour emmanuel nodé langlois président
des restos du coeur 78 ce week-end du 5
au 7 mars et la grande collecte
nationale de l'association les restos du
coeur pour l'occasion rencontre avec une
bénévole du comité départemental des
yvelines portrait un montage de rémi
lefebvre et je veux surtout pas qu'on
emploie le terme
rh parce que c'est un terme tellement
lourd tellement juridique tellement
salariale que non c'est pas possible
donc dans le monde bénévolat c'est je
m'occupe des bénévoles ont fui la
bénévoles qui s'occupent des vidéos
cela fait douze ans que sandrine vincent
51 ans maman de deux enfants et
habitants de chambourcy est bénévole au
sein des restos du coeur dans les
yvelines
d'abord directrice commerciale salariés
dans l'immobilier ou encore dans les
assurances puis 10 ans d'expatriation à
l'étranger en rentrant sandrine se lance
et intègre l'association
quand je suis rentré j'avais un peu une
rupture de réseau en fait professionnels
sociaux enfin c'était compliqué mes
enfants ont grandi un peu le syndrome du
nid vide et un matin ceux d'yvon ça peut
plus durer
la banquette c'est bien mais je veux
donner un sens à mes journées les restos
ont convenu parce que il y avait cette
notion de d'indépendance politique
religieuse je n'avais pas l'impression
d'adhérer à ni un parti ni à une
conviction en 2009 sandrine commence par
un poste administratif
mais très vite le terrain l'appel elle
passe trois ans au sein du centre
d'accueil de vernouillet aujourd'hui
elle forme les bénévoles au terrain mais
aussi à l'esprit restos j'oriente monde
est né vaut là vers les bénévoles
que ce soit pour le recrutement que ce
soit pour la formation que ce soit pour
leur parcours au sein des restos mon
souci c'est qu'ils vivent bien leur
bénévolat parce que c'est pas tous les
jours facile sans bénévoles y est pas la
sauce donc je mets toute mon énergie
j'essaye ma bonne humeur et parfois
certains phrasés pourra pour que tout le
monde se porte au mieux avec la crise
sanitaire beaucoup de choses ont changé
mais pas l'envi de sandrine de
poursuivre sa mission entre adaptation
au confinement aux mesures barrières et
re motivation des troupes
on a eu un temps de sidération d'une
quinzaine de jours assez compliqué on a
tous suspendus un peu et puis un moment
donné on s'est dit fou y retourner quoi
c'est pas possible donc on a mis en
place un système pendant toute la
période de confinement de colis on a
fait 69 des colis avec de la musique
avec des rires avec du froid mais on
s'en fichait ont retrouvé des humains et
on avait besoin de retrouver des humains
on est toujours très vigilant sur nounou
respect de mesures sanitaires tout en
mettant de plus en plus d'humains ou
d'humanité dans ces masques et dans ses
contacts compliqué donc c'est et voilà
notre priorité pour ce début d'année
c'est ça chaque année les restos du
coeur 78 accueille environ 15000
personnes pour 1200 bénévoles
ce week end c'est la grande collecte
nationale sandrine comme tous les autres
sera évidemment sur le bout nous
accueillons en plateau avec nous et manu
nodé langlois bonsoir au fort vous êtes
donc le président du comité
départemental des yvelines des restos du
coeur
alors je le rappelle ce vendredi 5
samedi 6 et dimanche 7 mars
c'est la grande collecte nationale de
l'association soixante quinze mille
bénévoles comme sandrine que l'on a pu
voir dans ce portrait seront présents
dans toute la france dans de nombreuses
grandes surfaces pour collecter des
denrées et donc alimentaires non
périssables ou des produits d'hygiène
l'an passé ses 7400 tonnes qui ont été
récupérés dans la france dans les
yvelines ce week-end 55 points de
collecte 700 bénévoles par jour c'est
beaucoup qu'en attendez-vous justement
de cette grande collecte en tout cas
yvelinoise nous avons en notre temps
plusieurs choses avancent et là un moyen
de
de rencontrer les gens donc de voir que
les la réaction des gens par rapport à
la crise actuelle de voir si l'année si
la générosité sera toujours au rendez
vous je sais pas si dans quelques
magasins depuis ce matin je pense que la
générosité est toujours là et les on a
un très bon accueil de la part des
personnes qui viennent faire leurs
courses
on est l'importance de la collecte
nationale c'est que ça nous permet
d'ouvrir le centre pendant ce qu'on
appelle la campagne d'été ce qui est le
plus connu pour les restos du coeur
c'est de la campagne d'hiver qui va
s'arrêter à la fin seuls prochaine
ensuite on va être fermé pendant deux
trois semaines suivant les cendres mais
ensuite on va réattaquer et la collecte
nationale est vraiment là un moment
essentiel pour nous pour pouvoir
distribuer des produits alimentaires sur
le reste de l'année
j'imagine que vous espérez collecter
autant voire plus que l'année dernière
on a tous on a toujours cet objectif là
parce que parce que c'est on a besoin
dont on a besoin d'aider les personnes
et puis oui je pense que on compte
toujours sur la générosité des gens qui
en général est là mais deux fêtes
d'année en année on s'aperçoit que on
arrive à collecter de plus en plus alors
cette année
j'imagine que la collecte a une saveur
particulière d'autant plus particulière
on s'en doute elle est d'autant plus
importante aussi avec la crise sanitaire
les bénéficiaires ont augmenté en tout
cas au niveau national quels ont été les
répercussions sur les restos du coeur
70-80 particulier alors sur les restos
du coeur au niveau du 78 globalement moi
je m'attendais à ce qu'il y ait une
vague forte en début d'année cette vague
on la sent toujours arriver mais par
contre il y à des centres dans lesquels
on a beaucoup de soucis parce que
on a des accroissements à deux chiffres
donc je pense dans le mantois ge penser
aux chances aux mureaux a plaisir à
trappes donc il y assemble de sang tout
ça comment ça va véritablement nous
poser nous poser des soucis
absolument et sur le profil donc de ces
nouvelles populations
il ya une nouvelle population qui est
apparu ce sont les étudiants on en parle
beaucoup avec la crise sanitaire
est-ce que c'est aussi le cas dans les
yvelines est ce que vous avez beaucoup
de jeunes d'étudiants qui viennent au
resto désormais alors on a on a une
demande de plus importante de la part
des étudiants
je crois ce qui est important c'est
qu'il ya une j'allais dire une
mutualisation au niveau des des
associations qui font de l'aide
alimentaire est on
on a essayé un petit peu de se répartir
les tâches donc oui les restos accueille
des étudiants même on va on va essayer
de peut être faire travailler certains
mais pour le moment oui il ya une
demande c'est indéniable la part des
jeunes de chivo bénéficiaire est ce que
vous l'avez vous la connaissez on
accueille environ 50% de gens qui ont
moins de 25 ans c'est énorme c'est un
chiffre énorme et c'est assez
monstrueuse drm donc c'est ça nous pose
véritablement beaucoup de beaucoup de
problèmes et ça pose de grosses de
beaucoup de questions pour l'avenir on
va revenir justement sur cette grande
collecte avec sandrine vincent qu'on a
écouté tout à l'heure dans le reportage
cette bénévole donc des restos du coeur
78 je le rappelle elle nous parle elle
de ce que représente cette grande
collecte annuelle vraiment pour elle on
écoute je suis d'une nature en dépit
touch pad un peu ronchon et c'est une
sorte de grand messe de réconciliation
avec l'humanité je suis toujours touchés
par la générosité de tout à chacun
ce qui me touche moi c'est cette envie
d'aider concrètement tout de suite et
dire ok de quoi vous avez besoin et ça
se voit sam ça m'émeut c1 trois journées
d'enfer
c'est le week-end restos ont fini à
genoux mais on est content de savoir
qu'on a bien fait les choses
en tant que président des restos du
coeur 78 qu'est ce que vous ressentez
chaque année vous à la fin de ce grand
week-end finalement solidaire est ce que
vous partagez les sentiments de la
bénévole sans vincent alors j'avais
exactement commencer par ça je trouve
que la qualité première de sandrine que
je connais depuis déjà pas mal d'années
sa qualité première c'est leur parti
alors on a tous notre caractère on l'a
mais elle quoi qu'il arrive on sait que
l'on peut compter sur elle et qu'elle va
être à l'écouté de l'autre donc pour moi
c'est la qualité première si vous voulez
donc ensuite au niveau
de là comment dirais-je dollars est-ce
que vous ressentez apprécié ce grand
week-end sawyer quel est votre soutien
vous personnel en a un petit peu un
petit parce que ce qu'ils s'envoyaient
l'a dit on est sur les genoux mais c'est
une fatigue saine
c'est à dire qu'on on se dit qu'on aura
le temps de récupérer l'arrière et on se
dit surtout que grâce à tout ça on va
pouvoir aider des gens et puis leur
apporter beaucoup de bonheur dernière
question très rapidement la semaine
prochaine 12 mars précisément se termine
la campagne d'hiver des restos du coeur
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
est-ce que vous avez un petit bilan en
faire dans les yvelines
alors aujourd'hui ce que je peux vous
dire c'est que on aura distribué entre
900 mille neuf cent cinquante mille
repas pendant la période d'hiver on peut
dire qu'on aime au même niveau
légèrement supérieur à ce qu'on faisait
en 2019 je ne parle pas de 1020 parce
qu'à cause du co by death avaient
considérablement chuté donc si on fait
une comparaison 2021 2020 samara sarapp
aucun sens mais par contre je ne vous
cache pas qu on est quand même on est
quand même assez inquiet sur ce qui
risque de vous arriver dans les quelques
mois qui vont venir dans la pré commande
il est absolument
merci manuel nodé langlois d'avoir été
avec nous sur ce plateau faire je vous
remercie de m'avoir accueilli
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comme chaque semaine votre rendez-vous
en partenariat avec les surligneurs ce
collectif qui décrypte les déclarations
des politiques et des personnalités
publiques
aujourd'hui retour sur l'impartialité de
la justice dans la sphère nicolas
sarkozy on écoute vincent couronne
fondateur des surligneurs et docteur en
droit à l'université versailles saint
quentin
nicolas sarkozy a été condamné le 1er
mars 2021 dans l' affaire dite des
écoutes à trois ans d'emprisonnement
dont un an ferme pour corruption active
et trafic d'influencé
sans surprise l'ancien président de la
république compte faire appel pour se
défendre
nicolas sarkozy utilise un argument en
remettant en cause notamment
l'impartialité de ses juges il est vrai
que l'impartialité de la justice est un
principe fondamental et qu'il est
protégé par la convention européenne des
droits de l'homme que la france a
ratifié et qu'elle a donc l'obligation
de faire respecter
nicolas sarkozy qui avait traité les
juges lorsqu'il était président de la
république de petits pois carottes se
ressemblent tous même aux origines mêmes
formations disait-il se plaindrait de ce
que les juges désormais est trouvé avec
affaire des écoutes un moyen de se
venger et il est vrai comme le dit
nicolas sarkozy que l'impartialité
s'effondre dès que l'accusé a la
conviction personnelle que le juge
n'était pas impartial l'apparence de
partialité suffire et à dire donc que le
juge est partial l'ancien président
menace donc de saisir la cour européenne
des droits de l'homme pour faire
reconnaître cette partialité sauf qu'à
regarder de plus près les raisons que la
cour européenne des droits de l'homme
retiens tu habituellement le cas sarkozy
laisse peu de chance à nicolas karr
encore faut-il que cette apparence de
partialité soit confirmée par un
observateur objectif nous dit la cour de
ce point de vue il n'est pas sûr que cet
observateur aurait le même avis que
nicolas sarkozy si la cour européenne
des droits de l'homme suivait le
raisonnement de l'ancien président il
suffirait à n'importe quel accusé ou
prévenu d'insulter tout la magistrature
pour échapper à tout procès
l'actualité de la semaine dans les
yvelines cecelia gars tsongo qui vous la
résume en 78 secondes rentrée scolaire
perturbé les écoles de chambourcy sont
fermés pour au moins une semaine après
la découverte de treize cas du variant
sud africain du commis 19 une grande
campagne de dépistage a été organisée
dans le gymnase de la ville
des tests salivaires seront également
déployés dans les écoles primaires des
épines
clap de fin pour les soldes d'hiver un
bilan plutôt positif au centre juan les
chaînes des clayes-sous-bois qui a pu
rester ouverts grâce à ces espaces à
l'extérieur puisque l'on parle commerce
le département des yvelines soutient les
commerçants de chevreuse en leur
attribuant une aide d'urgence
au total ce sont 48 500 euros qui ont
été refinancés par le département pour
la commune le port du masque est
dorénavant obligatoire partout dans les
yvelines décision prise par le préfet
pour freiner l'épidémie de kovy 19
il est aussi interdit de consommer de
l'alcool sur la voie publique
le mans c'est davantage sur le quartier
des savoirs qui sera sorti de terre
d'ici 2030 à guyancourt situés sur les
anciennes friches de thales ce nouveau
quartier accueillera la ligne 18 la
future gare et environ 2000 logements et
commerces
le plan de restructuration des collèges
a été dévoilé par le département 15
établissements devraient être construits
d'ici 2025 pour un coût total de 525
millions d'euros
[Musique]
pour refermer ce 7,8 week end malgré les
restrictions sanitaires et évidemment en
respectant les gestes barrière celle
yaga tsongo vous propose de découvrir ou
redécouvrir l'arboretum de versailles
chèvreloup ce dimanche 7 mars le parc
sera gratuit pour tous les visiteurs
il en sera de même tous les premiers
dimanches du mois
[Musique]
l'arboretum de versailles chèvre louvre
à rouvert ses portes ce lundi 1er mars
après cinq mois de fermeture
et pour fêter cela le parc est gratuit
ce dimanche 7 mars
nous accueillons frédéric achille
bonjour bonjour vous êtes le directeur
adjoint des jardin botanique du muséum
national d'histoire naturelle
le parc compte 200 hectares et près de
2500 espèces végétales
quelle est la plus remarquable en ce
moment selon vous alors c'est difficile
de choisir mais là on est vraiment tout
début de saison donc c'est une première
floraison en en particulier des pruniers
ou des cerisiers alors il ya les
premiers cerisiers japonais qui
commencent à fleurir dans la zone
horticole au centre de l'arboretum par
exemple que j'aime beaucoup parce qu une
floraison très très vive très coloré
puis de dix mille arbres sont à
découvrir ici si je me trompe pas oui
orient environ dix mille arbres c'est
difficile de les compter tous parce que
c'est une très grande surface alors
l'ensemble des espèces d'arbres sont
inventoriés donc on a une base de
données de collection
et puis il ya des arbres qui sont
intéressants différentes périodes de
l'année est longue la tête au début des
floraisons mais de tout au long de
l'année il y aura des floraisons
intéressante à voir le parc se compose
de trois zones géographiques c'est bien
ça est-ce que vous pouvez m'expliquer
peut-être un peu plus c'est sa sueur sur
les 200 hectares du parc
les collections sont organisés en
différentes zones donc les trois zones
géographiques qui dépendent donc de
l'origine des espèces qui sont cultivés
ici donc une zone européenne et zone
américaine une zone asiatique
et puis des zones systématique ou des
espèces regrouper par affinités
botanique qui peut venir à l'arboretum
finalement est ce que tous les publics
sont les bienvenus
alors bien sûr tous les publics sont
bienvenues alors il ya des choses à voir
pour tout le monde en fait pour les
personnes qui connaissent pas du tout la
botanique c'est simplement une promenade
dans la nature on découvre beaucoup de
des espaces naturels de plantes sauvages
des animaux aussi donc il ya tout un
aspect de promenade qui est très
agréable et puis pour les spécialistes
des collections spécialisées de tout de
tout type
on a beaucoup de conifères par exemple
on est aussi des plantes fleuries comme
des cerisiers ou des pruniers qui a un
aspect très haut le mental est ce qu'on
peut aurait fait faire le tour en en
quoi une journée ça c'est possible
alors on trouve aux différentes visites
en fait il ya un petit parcours rapide
en 2 heures qui permet de voir un peu
un extrait de l'arboretum et puis il ya
pas comment donner qui fait 11
kilomètres qui permet de découvrir
l'ensemble du terrain est d'ailleurs
l'ensemble des paysages et puis selon
les saisons en fait il ya des points
d'intérêt plus ou moins intéressants par
exemple la floraison des cerisiers ou
bien l'automne des feuillages des
érables japonais et sur la saison donc
on oriente le visiteur vers différents
points de l'arboretum qui permet d'avoir
une visite à la carte est alors
aujourd'hui là on est début mars
qu'est ce qu'on peut voir alors c'est
vraiment le tout début de floraison des
arbres
il ya les soldes qui commencent à sortir
leurs chatons qui sont assez jolis et
puis il ya le début des cerisiers alors
on a cette année faut savoir qu'on ne
peut pas 15 jours d'avancé donc les
cerisiers japonais commencent à fleurir
les variétés les plus précoces mais ça
va s'étaler jusqu'au mois d'avril
et puis après on aura les pommiers qui
commencera furet un peu plus tard et on
a également des pruniers sauvages
qui sont assez répartis dans l'arboretum
très bien et bien merci beaucoup
frédéric achille d'avoir été notre
invité
[Musique]
c'est la fin de votre 7,8 week end merci
de l'avoir suivi l'information revient
lundi à 18h en direct dans le 7-8
journal présenté par grégory canal et
vous pourrez revoir cette émission et
toutes les autres en replay sur notre
site internet tv 78 points comme et
notre application mobile tv 78 et d'ici
là une très belle soirée un très bon
week end
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]